hi this is Prussia Walker in this video
I'm going to explain to you how point
nine repeating is not equal to one in a
number system known as the surreal
numbers now you probably heard that
point nine repeating is equal to one and
you've probably seen some very
convincing proofs of it and what you've
learned in school is actually true it's
true for the numbers we commonly use
called the real numbers these are the
numbers that include zero the positive
numbers the negative numbers fractions
and the rationals and together all of
these numbers make up the familiar
number line but to explain how point
nine repeating is not equal to one we're
going to have to go into the details of
what exactly a real number is and how we
can build up the real numbers from a set
theoretic construction so we're going to
start out by building up the real
numbers in a set theory manner and the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to build up zero and the positive
numbers the process works
it starts out just from the empty set so
originally we just have one object and
the set contains nothing and we're going
to label this set as the number zero now
that we have the number zero we can
define a new number as being equal to
the set that contains the object zero
and we're going to say that this is the
number one we're going to continue the
process and put a set that contains the
number one inside of it and call it two
so with this process we can inductively
build up all of the positive numbers by
saying the new number n is equal to the
set of the previous number n minus one
now we have to build up the negative
numbers and we can do that by writing it
as a pair of two positive numbers
so the positive numbers we already know
we can define as the pair of the
positive number comma zero to define the
negative numbers we're going to flip
that so negative 1 will be 0 comma 1
negative 2 will be 0 comma 2 and so on
so in this way we can take the positive
numbers and build up all the negative
numbers to build up the fractions or all
the rationals we're going to have
another ordered pair of any of the
integers we've just built so the
fraction 1/2 we can write out as ordered
pair of the number 1 and the number 2
finally we can complete the real numbers
by defining the Irrational's and this is
a bit complicated but let me just tell
you you can define numbers like negative
square root of 2 from the sets we've
already built up and that's how you
build up the real numbers now the reason
I did all this is that it'll give you a
sense of how we build up the surreal
numbers so we also build them up from
sets but the first set we have it's not
just simply an empty set it's going to
be an empty set that has a left and a
right side the empty set we're going to
define as the number zero but now these
sets we're going to use have a left and
a right side so now we can build up two
more numbers once we have the number 0
by putting a 0 on the left side or
putting a 0 on the right side of the
divider we can define the first number
as 1 and we're going to define the other
number as negative 1 and the surreal
numbers are built up in this manner
where each time we're going to take one
of the numbers we built up and we're
going to see what happens when we put
that number on the left side or the
right side or some combination of
numbers we've already built up
so the surreal numbers are actually
built up by a branching process we start
out with zero then we build the numbers
negative 1 and 1 and each of those
numbers can branch out to build
different numbers of their own once we
have these new numbers we branch out and
build out new numbers and eventually if
we keep ranching out infinitely many
times we're going to generate all of the
real numbers all of the fractions all of
the irrational x' etc all of the
positive and negative numbers so that's
how the surreal numbers are built up but
what's interesting about the surreal
numbers is that we end up on the
infinite branch branching process we end
up with some weird numbers so let me
write out a number for you let's say we
have a set we're on the left side we
just have the number 0 and on the right
side we have 1 1/2 1/4 1/8 and so on
each time we divide by 2 1/16 and so on
and this list continues infinitely so
this is a valid surreal number and this
number by the way the surreal numbers
are defined is going to be a positive
number that's greater than zero but
smaller than any other positive number
and this number will write out as
Epsilon and you can think about this
number as being 1 divided by infinity
because this number is basically the
number that's greater than 0 but it's
smaller than all other positive numbers
so you can think about it as maybe point
zero repeating with the one at the end
we can continue there's another weird
number we can write out where we have a
zero one half 3/4 7/8 and so on on the
left side each time you know we would
have 15 16 and so on and on the right
side we have 1 so this is another valid
surreal number
and this number is going to be defined
so that it's greater than every positive
number that's less than one but it's
still less than one and this number will
exactly be one minus Epsilon and you can
think about it as point nine repeating
so we've come up with the very weird
number point nine repeating which is
clearly not equal to 1 because 1 was
equal to the set which just had zero on
the left side so we've come up with the
number system where point nine repeating
is not the same as one I will end that
the surreal numbers are pretty cool it
turns out that the surreal numbers can
also be derived as values from a game
called hackenbush or red in blue players
alternately take turns and you can
define values of the game depending on
how the red and blue sticks are placed
so what this means is that all of life
is numbers and all of numbers are simply
a game and therefore all of life is a
game I hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can catch me
on my blog mind your decisions on
Twitter at pressure Walker or get my
books at Amazon